it's one of the hardest things to do for
a number of reasons from all the way
from building an act to performing the
ACT
um uh and in fact I used to when when we
were riding Goodwill Hunting Ben and I
were unemployed so we'd write all day
but one of the things I used to do was
I'd go to The Improv because we had no
idea what we were doing last time and we
knew nothing about like structure or any
we were just like writing scenes and
jamming them together you know so it was
a really inefficient way to write oh
interesting because I'd write all day
and then I'd go and sit there and my
relaxation was watching these young
Comics come in and write it gave me so
much hope kind of watching them develop
through the week I just love that
process and I love watching it and yet
we found this time around when we
actually did an outline for what we were
going to write and like had an idea of
what we were doing every day we actually
wrote really fast and I think that was
just a product of having made movies for
30 years